well Brian there are a lot of different
apps and services out there that allow
you to leave your pets in the care of a
sitter but it's often hard to tell if
someone is even licensed to do so so
Victoria Saha dug deeper into the rules
and the regulations for pet boarding in
our area after a Henderson Family says
their dog died in the care of a sitter
but it's what happened after that's
really disturbing Victoria
Denise the Melendez family claimed the
dog sitter went to Great Lengths to lie
about what happened to their dog and
they say that's what's so heartbreaking
to them
Teddy a 12 year old Shih Tzu was a big
lover for a man's best friend he's got
big dog energy and a little dog body
Christopher Melendez thought his best
friend would be in the best care where
the sitter he found online someone his
family used a few times before they were
happy it didn't seem like an issue but
on Monday morning Melendez got a call
The Sitter said Teddy escaped with a few
of the other dogs the other dogs were
found but Teddy wasn't you know I know
Teddy Teddy's not one that Strays far
she had gone to you know some of the
neighbors to ask around Melinda says he
put up flyers and went door to door
asking the sitter's neighbor if they saw
Teddy when the neighbors told him the
sitter never went to them that's when he
knew something was wrong and confronted
her again she explained to me the story
that another dog she was taking care of
you know must have gotten into a fight
with him they had come home from
wherever they were and found Teddy you
know allegedly gasping for breath
Melendez says this sitter claimed she
was going to take Teddy to the vet when
he died on the way but instead of still
taking him to the vet Melendez says they
did the unthinkable they decided to take
him out to you know off Lake Mead
Parkway into the desert and you know try
and bury him Melendez says he had the
sitter's husband take him to where they
buried Teddy and confirmed it was him
that really sucked
to you know see
see my dog like that on Thursday I went
to the sitter's house in Henderson we
aren't mentioning her name or business
because there haven't been any charges
did Teddy die under your car yes he did
okay can you tell us what happened yes
and it was an accident so why not tell
the family right away what hi because he
had told me the thought the mother had
an embolism and she would have found out
about it and that's when I didn't say
anything did you have a business license
to run out of this house you answered to
my lawyer okay can I get his information
she shut the door on us but we checked
with the city of Henderson and found out
the business license number the sitter
advertised on social media was invalid
they also say the city of Henderson does
not issue animal establishment licenses
and or permits to residential addresses
as for Melendez it's hard for him to
imagine the suffering Teddy went through
it kills me thinking that you know maybe
maybe Teddy was alive or something and
you know he could have been helped
during my interaction with the sitter
you might have heard a lot of dogs
barking that were coming out of that
house she claims her business is closed
and that those four dogs are hers but
the city of Henderson says you can only
have three dogs Melendez says Animal
Control is taking over and they're doing
a necropsy on Teddy to find out exactly
how he died I of course will be
continuing to work on the story and
bring you any updates we get Denise oh
that is just heartbreaking Victoria also
did check with Clark County by the way
uh its response it's unlikely this kind
of business would be approved it's
similar to a kennel which is something
you would find in a commercial area not
residential